un enjeu mondial à ne pas prendre à la
légère la nouvelle année va marquer le
début de multiples campagnes de
vaccination à travers le globe en europe
nombreux sont les pays à tabler sur des
première inoculation qui s'étaleront sur
le premier semestre 2021 l'espagne
l'allemagne ou encore l'italie
n'attendent que le feu vert des
autorités européennes
celui ci est prévu durant la seconde
quinzaine de décembre
la gratuité du remède à d'ores et déjà
été annoncées par rome madrid et berlin
régulièrement critiqué pour sa gestion
de la crise sanitaire le premier
ministre britannique boris johnson joue
la carte de la rapidité en misant sur le
vaccin développé par pfizer et bayonne
tech
les premières doses du sérum
germano-américain seront administrés dès
la semaine prochaine
d'après les autorités à la demande du
président poutine la russie a déjà
commencé à vacciner ces militaires
depuis le 27 novembre et la semaine
prochaine devrait débuter l'injection à
grande échelle du vaccin spoutnik v
actuellement en phase iii et efficace à
95% selon ses développeurs
les autorités chinoises ont décidé de
prendre les devants henry annonce avoir
déjà vacciner un million de ses citoyens
notamment les plus fragiles
l'empiré du milieu espère ainsi
atteindre une immunité collective
pékin a opté pour le vaccin développé
par le géant chinois sinopharm côté
américain la campagne de vaccination
sera immédiatement lancée après
validation de lagence des médicaments
plusieurs millions d'américains
pourraient se voir injecter les vaccins
de moderna et firebug en teck